The cosine outputs the ratio of 2 lengths
which means that the unit of measurement that the cosine returns is 1.
The cosine does not return meters or kilograms, it returns bare numbers.
So whatever is in front of that cosine determines the measurement unit of the result.
The result is not measured in days.
We can immediately reject these.
The result is measured in meters.
It can only be this one or that one.
The cosine and the sine range between -1 and +1.
If you multiply by something x 10⁻⁹m,
We would be dealing with very, very tiny lengths.
That's not what we are into here.
It has to be the first one.
This is the radius of the orbit of the moon around the earth.
Let me do these in reverse order.
The radius of the orbit of the moon should not appear inside here.
This has to do with the period of the moon's orbit.
How long does it take the moon to make one full orbit around earth?
27 days. It must not be the meters.
Which is also clear from the units.
If we have meters in here, something has to cancel the meters.
We have to have an angle in here.
If we speak of radians, again, something without measurements units.
There must not be any measurement unit in here.
If it were meters, these meters would have to cancel somehow.
How would I do that?
Not with time, obviously. Seconds or days don't cancel with meters.
Once we are here, it's clear that we have to use the division.
Days divided by days.
This gets rid of the measurement units.
We can't mulitiply by days, otherwise we would be getting days squared.
And the remaining choice, 2π x t.
Not this one. Not this one.
If we let t grow by 27 days, 1 complete period,
the numerator increases by 2π x 27 days.
And this ratio increases by 2π x 27 days, divided by 27 days, by 2π.
As t advances by one period, this ratio advances by 2π,
but that's precisely what we need for cosine and sine.
The angle has to advance by 2π 360°.
One full revolution.